Welcome back everyone this is going to be my new
green lantern video they're just explaining more
about what's happening with green lantern
in the larger dc universe both the green
lantern hbo series and what's going on with the
diggle version of green lantern we finally found
out when they're going to actually cover his
storyline so if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos and zack
snyder even showed off the wayne carr version
of green lantern that he shot for the justice
league snyder cut then warner brothers made him
delete this is actually the video of
that with some special effects laid in
that's awesome
seems pretty cool it's too bad the studio
made him get rid of that but if we hear
anything about them adding that back into
a future version of that movie eventually
we'll find out but i think the reason why they
made him cut it out is because of jon stewart
green lantern that they want to introduce in a
future green lantern movie in the next couple
of years i will be doing episode videos for the
green lantern hbo series when that premieres which
sounds like it's going to be next year because
they've already started casting some of the big
green lantern characters we just heard about finn
wit rock being cast as guy gardner it's going to
be jumping around in the timeline he's more of
an 80s 90s kind of green lantern even though he's
still around in present day for the green lantern
corps but they just announced that jeremy irvine
is going to be their alan scott so they're going
to do his origin story obviously he's a very young
actor they did say they're going to jump around
in the timeline but i don't know if that also
means that we're going to see him cross over with
guy gardner and some of the other more modern day
green lanterns like we have jessica cruz we have
simon bass they're doing sinestro i know there's a
big question about what's going on with hal jordan
and jon stewart it sounds like they are kind of
bookmarking them for a future green lantern corps
movie that they're still apparently developing
right now so i know the other big question is is
what's going on with diggle green lantern in the
middle of all this because there's a lot of green
lantern related stuff happening in the dc universe
they spent all that time crossing over the green
lantern movie footage from the ryan reynolds
green lantern movie in crisis on infinite earth
even though they sort of cut ryan reynolds out i
think just to be more ambiguous about it but you
do see the green lantern ring carrying him to owa
funny enough ryan reynolds actually did a
re-watch of the green lantern movie he said
that he never actually watched it since it came
out in the theater like he watched it once and
then that was it so we got really drunk and
actually watched it through he was actually
pretty kind during his rewatch even though he's
always making jokes about himself as green lantern
please don't make a super suit green or animated
can i wait to see what kind of green lantern jokes
he has in deadpool 3 because by that time warner
brothers will have actually released episodes of
the green lantern hbo series but david ramsey
was just doing this big interview explaining
the future of diggle and the aeroverse what that
story is going to be and how they're going to
cover the green lantern moment from crisis
on infinite earths and that scene from the
arrow finale so quick recap if you didn't watch
all the arrow episodes during the aero finale
there's sort of like an end credits end tag scene
explaining what's happening with diggle next he's
accepted a job in metropolis so he's taking the
whole family they're packing their house up and
he's in the process of like literally driving the
car away when he sees a meteorite crash to earth
and finds this glowing rock he opens the box this
is actually the behind the scenes for that this
is what the box actually looked like while they
were filming mur guggenheim one of the producers
on the show and the person who wrote some of
these scenes actually kind of explained that
warner brothers had very specific rules about how
they were allowed to do this green lantern scene
like they couldn't show him putting the ring
on they couldn't actually show you the ring
they had to do it pulp fiction style where they
just show the green light shining on his face so
you're like what's in the box but obviously you
know what's in the box it's a green lantern ring
then a while to the season they announced that
diggle was going to come back and cross over onto
a couple of the other shows like the superman
tv show legends of tomorrow and that's where
his story would continue and move forward in the
arrowverse naturally everyone just assumed that
they would cover the green lantern story on the
superman tv show at least maybe some on legends of
tomorrow so david ramsey in his recent interview
just clarified where that's going to happen and
where they're going to cover that story so he
said the legends of tomorrow episode is just
like a one-off weird funny story and he's going
to be playing a historical figure this is what
he looks like so obviously they're not going to be
doing any kind of green lantern stuff during that
but the other four episodes that he's doing will
actually tell the green lantern story that'll be
on superman batwoman and supergirl i believe he's
crossing over to all those shows with cameos and
it'll all be connected with this overarching
story of him getting the green lantern ring
that's where he said they're going to cover
the story of what happens next with that green
glowing box so david ramsey explained get it the
diggle actually refused the call like he actually
turned down the opportunity so even though he
didn't say it explicitly he basically said the
diggle saw the ring and decided to just ignore
it like he threw it in the back of his closet
i'm going to read what david ramsey said so
i'm paraphrasing here he said after crisis on
infinite earth he got back his wife who was
abducted by the monitor talking about lila
and he got back his daughter sarah who was taken
out of existence by flashpoint so part of diggle's
story is the last thing that he would want to do
right now is receive an invitation from something
otherworldly talking about the green lantern ring
the green lantern corps because he finally has his
family back and he lost his best friend to some
other worldliness so david ramsey goes on to say
that he refused the invitation of whatever was
in the box obviously we know exactly what's in
the box it's a ring but then he goes on to say
there are consequences to that in the story of
what he will do next is a part of what we're going
to tell through these four episodes and i think
the whole idea like is he goes on to explain the
idea that they want to keep diggle a very grounded
character like he was never one of the characters
with superpowers he didn't even get a super suit
right away that's why david ramsey says anytime
that he would go fast with the flash he would run
him around he would throw up they kind of turned
it into a running joke over the seasons during the
crossovers david ramsey talks about how diggle was
always amazed when he saw someone flying like he
just couldn't believe a lot of these crazy things
that were happening around him so he says when he
comes back on the superman tv show this will be a
very very early preliminary look at what happens
from his refusal the consequences and what it
means to his destiny the way he talks about it he
says there's going to be some preliminary physical
effects to his refusal of whatever's in the box
like crazy pounding headaches so basically the
idea is that eventually diggle will become green
lantern and they'll just cover that in a bigger
story maybe one of the future crossovers where
you actually see him in a full-blown green lantern
suit but it sounds like it's going to take a while
for them to work up to that like they're going
to pull the taffy on that as much as possible
why tell it in one episode when we can tell
it over the course of two or three years
as for him showing up on the green lantern hbo
series where they're doing like the real big
budget green lantern stuff i guess it's always
possible i mean everything is connected if you're
talking about crisis on infinite earth i mean they
crossed over ezra miller's justice league flash
with the grant gust and flash of the arrowverse
so they did that technically everything is canon
but the way they talk about it i don't think that
he's going to start out at least in season 1 on
that green lantern hbo series if he did cross over
it wouldn't be till a later season because i think
they kind of want to do their own thing with the
green lantern hbo stuff even though technically
it's actually the same berlanti people that
are making the green lantern show that make all
the arrowverse shows it's literally all the same
people but i think they're approaching it for more
of like a matt reeves type of batman perspective
so like for instance how are all the dc movies
going to be connected going forward like you have
robert pattinson batman who's a very young version
of the character but his movie is taking place in
present day so how do you reconcile that with the
ben affleck version of batman on the main version
of justice league earth you just say multiverse
that's how you explain everything they're really
going to dig into that deeper on the flash movie
where ezra miller's flash will travel to the earth
that michael keaton's batman is on like we'll just
call it the burton verse whichever designation you
want to give that it sounds like they're going to
tease a lot of other easter eggs from alternate
versions of earth too the same way when we first
saw the flash in flash season 2 go to earth
2 and they tease all these other images from
all the other shows and some of the movies they
eventually paid all that stuff off but it took
like seven years to get there so when it comes to
crossing over the aeroverse people with a lot of
these hbo series like the green lantern hbo show
for instance because we're talking about diggle i
would just have realistic expectations about that
like probably not going to happen in season one i
think the idea with the green lantern hbo series
is they want that to have more synergy with what's
happening in the future movies more connected
to the movies like the future green lantern core
movie than it will be to the cw tv shows because
of the whole hal jordan jon stewart of it all like
why would you announce a giant green lantern hbo
series and not do your two most popular characters
well probably because you're going to save them
for the movie but because they're doing a green
lantern core movie i think the whole idea is
is they want to have some synergy with this
green lantern hbo series because for instance
matt reeves batman hbo series that he's doing
is basically a spin-off of the batman movie it'll
involve a lot of the same characters they haven't
completely announced every single character that's
going to feature but gordon will be one of the
main characters and it'll be jeffrey wright
playing gordon on that hbo series so it's the
exact same situation with the marvel disney plus
series where you have the movie actors showing up
on the tv shows that doesn't mean that you'll
never see robert pattinson's character cross
over with the other justice league characters it
just means that it's probably not going to happen
anytime soon matt reeves is just one of the few
directors who specifically said i didn't want to
cross this over directly with the other stuff
i didn't have to worry about what was going on
with that but everything is technically connected
through the multiverse so that's why his batman is
taking place on earth too and i think they're
kind of treating the green lantern hbo series
the same way relative to the cw tv shows in diggle
green lantern it was a couple restrictions they'll
just let the arrowverse people do whatever they
want to do with diggle's green lantern the funny
connection between diggle and jon stewart though
because for a long time people are like will he
become the jon stewart of the arrowverse hello
john do i know you you're not wearing your ring
things must be different here eventually they
did canonize it so the diggle's real name
is stuart so he's john diggle stewart because
his stepfather is general roy stewart so they
just had some fun with that but that's more of
like an easter egg you have to think of that as
sort of like an elseworlds alternate universe
version of jon stewart but when he eventually
does get that green lantern suit they'll just
continue to call him diggle but hopefully that
explains what's going on with all the green
lantern stuff that's happening in the next year
the first big dc hbo series that's going to drop
episodes is going to be james gunn's peacemaker
series with john cena's character from suicide
squad like the marvel disney plus series is
basically going to be a spin-off of the suicide
squad series but he didn't say if it's going to
be a prequel or a sequel to the movie all those
episodes will be dropping in january next year
of course i'll do videos for those as well
i believe there's going to be eight of them
everyone posts all your theories about diggle
green lantern do you think that he'll ever cross
over with that green lantern hbo series maybe in
season 2 season 3. we've got marvel loki episodes
that are coming up real soon i'll be doing videos
for all those make sure you have alerts enabled
for my channel so you don't miss anything
click here for that brand new loki episode 1
trailer and opening scene and click here for my
brand new venom 2 trailer let there be carnage
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!